[Music]  for more than 50 years  CBS viewers have been treated to this  holiday greeting the hand-drawn  animation first aired on this network in  1966 it was the work of artist ro  Blackmon known for his new yorker covers  a series of drawings Blackman did in the  early 60s served as the basis for the  classic cartoon the artwork was simple  and so was the story but it won the  hearts of millions with its universal  holiday message of goodwill now CBS is  paying homage to the vintage cartoon  with a new set of holiday greetings that  share in the essence and message of the  original CBS along with the Swedish  design firm brick and Anchor Point  Animation spent months creating five new  holiday promos that feature animated  creatures finding the true meaning of  the season the new animated greetings  made their debut on Thanksgiving Day and  will run until the end of December  but because of its minute long running  time  CBS only aired the original once this  year  [Music]